welcome everybody h3
tv is live once again my friends
coming to you raw and regala
every monday and thursday
for now hey come on
boy we've got a good fun episode today
h3tv
how's everyone doing out there feeling
good
good how was your weekend weekend was
good
we got the fan back got the yeah i've
had the fan back i mean that's old news
at this point
first weekend with the fan back though
is it the first weekend
it is okay maybe so still still fresh
news
yeah and it's become your family's heart
and soul
wow um
how was your guys weekend it was good it
had a lot of final fantasy 14. i'm not
gonna lie
oh i'm almost i've almost completed the
original game
i'm at the end of the the main quest so
wait how what level are you
48 or 49 or something okay and it goes
up to 50 right
yeah it goes up to 50. the whole end
raid thing is kind of annoying because
it's like a billion
unskippable cutscenes yeah it takes
forever
dude and we know how you feel about
cutscenes it just takes forever
uh but i'm really enjoying i'm 56 or 57
now i'm really enjoying
really enjoying what can i say once you
get when you skip
all the dialogue at all the cutscenes
it's a great game
um okay so today we're gonna be talking
about
the first thing on our roster here
is crowder's nightmare a lot of you guys
remember the debate
quote unquote we had with sam cedar
and uh uh
crowder stephen crowder how was crowder
doing he was in the hospital last
i heard uh
yeah he's been in and out of the
hospital for the last uh month or so
um does not seem to be uh
well he had like heart surgery or
something for a con
i think it's a congenital thing that
he's had since birth
and then i think there were like
complications and stuff so yeah he's um
he's not doing uh that well i'm not
gonna make any jokes about it
i take the man's health deadly seriously
that
was terrible wording the hell i thought
ethan was a stand-up guy
i swear anyway i wish him well that's
what i'm trying to say i wish him well
and um that's this animation came out it
has nothing to do with the fact that you
know he's in the hospital we wish him
well we don't we don't wish harm on
anybody right oh my god oh
oh jesus what'd you see i just pulled up
his twitter to see if there were any
updates and he's posting
some really yo send me that no no no no
no i want to see it personally
don't put it on stream well don't switch
to it ian here send it to me in discord
i'll describe it to you guys
so what is crowder tweeting
something that shocked and horrified dan
yeah i'm a little squeamish when it
comes to this stuff and that was what
did he show like an image of his heart
or something
no oh just a bag of blood no that's not
scroll down from that okay so crowder
here let me update you
day three another leader i've lost 13
pounds of
in the span of a weekend jesus of blood
uh i i imagine that's just of weight and
now here's a video
of what in the [ __ ] yeah that's what
made me
is this his back yes oh wow
so it looks like they're doing some kind
of spinal tap or something
yeah um they're just inserting a huge
a massive needle into his back yeah
wow do not wish that on anyone
whoa mamma mia fluid in his lungs says
somebody in the uh
oh so that's what my mom did they stick
a needle it's so crazy
they stick a needle through your back
into your lungs to drain fluid
if he's got that much fluid in his lungs
yeah that's that's that's a bad
situation
yeah no i mean
well at any rate while wishing him well
i do need to celebrate this uh cartoon
that was made
by this guy ammon
amen animations and this i mean this
thing is a masterpiece i mean
it's it's just it's just unbelievable
um i have to share it with you guys
okay
right all right let me check this
[Music]
okay all right i'll give you a countdown
and then i'll uh three
two all right okay i'm really glad to
have uh my next guest on the show and
i've always said this i always respect
people who um enter the enter into the
arena
um and you know we've had a lot of
debates on this show which is different
from like a change my mind where we sit
down have conversations
but to appreciate the guy making the
time because a lot of people haven't uh
you know some of you like them some of
you don't same can be said for me ethan
klein from
h3h3 uh ethan thank you thanks man for
making the time
you're very welcome and i just want to
say by the way
watching it animated you can tell how
nervous he was going into it
like he mean by just focusing on the
audio of it yeah like you can hear in
his voice
because he's made him all clammy and
sweaty and stuff but you could tell he
was so
nervous even before he knew sam was
there
i think i used something like that yeah
and i think you're right because i don't
think i'm a very good debater
i think you know that so i don't want to
make it too easy for you
oh okay so i prepared
okay yes all right so what we're gonna
talk about
is uh what we were gonna talk about is
you know the initial quote that happened
he really made me look like such a
lunatic the animator and
i think he's looking off there uh the
initial quote that kind of
was turned into um a little bit of a
meme
which wasn't intentional i was just
curious they're supposed to be dancing
was you saying you don't even have to
think about it
talked about this through playful
ribbing and an aggregation of medical
authorities and scientific voices
to make an informed and rational
decision people saying it's chris
redfield from resident evil
stephen do you know that um the spartans
are
that they are like uh practice man love
with children
oh jeez okay so this is what's gonna
happen what did i tell you he was gonna
do anything he could to avoid
oh oh there he is oh no sam cedar what
up
what a [ __ ] nightmare
dude sam
this is too real this is really what
crowder went through
come on stephen
[Applause]
i think we should need to have a meeting
with his dad irony alert stephen
stop being a [ __ ] stop being a baby
you're like come on stephen
i think he lost the right to the to
those holsters i think he has to retire
them
oh sweetie what kind of a [ __ ] am i
talking to what happened to you
joe rogan turning into a gorilla
it's just so amazing
nightmare it was a dope movie nightmare
can't wait for avatar too avatar too
[Applause]
oh my god
cold feet again
wake up
the glowing glass is such a great uh
like creepy anime touch
look
one because crowder said he wanted to
see his eyes right
right
[Applause]
not that limp dick
yeah exactly
brain you're acting kind of weird today
dude not [ __ ] arthur
not arthur he's gonna clench his fist
oh no
dude not arthur with the clenched fist
[Music]
[Applause]
the velveteen rabbit eyes it's the
rabbit eyes that he
feared he kept saying to sam let me see
your velveteen rabbit eyes well there
they are
[Music]
and then i believe this is uh crowder's
beating heart
[Music]
he gave his heart back
oh no yeah
some kind of a twin peaks ask backwards
[Music]
he says this is the guy who made it ham
and hockey says thank you for watching i
hope you enjoyed this series finale of
arthur
this yeah but anyway if you guys want to
sub this guy
i'm down to watch another one because
this guy is a freaking g he didn't want
him jordan peterson that like
so magnus magnus opus
because he's got a big one right is that
what they call it the magnum opus
you guys want to watch another one i
feel like we should because um
the jordan peterson one is like bro it
made me want to die
of just it's so beautiful this is art
you guys
people are saying there's a hassan one
yeah i haven't watched this on one we
should watch that
anyway his name is eamonn a-a-m-o-n
animations we'll drop a link in the
description this vod is going to go up
on youtube by the way immediately
after and we will drop the link there
did you
i have the the hassan one here guru
hasan abi
oh so the frogs that's a twitch thing
right like they admirers
it is but i'm not too familiar with that
ian might know a little bit more about
the frog well it's the pepe frog right
that's a reference to that
i don't know because twitch thing is a
frog okay
oh his viewers yeah his head is all
[ __ ] small
that's awesome i'm here to talk to you
today about
music arts fashion one of the greatest
problems that our generations are facing
oh my god the biggest scourge courage
that affects our society
dude i love his tiny head cultural and
social progress we've seen
is the battle against intellectual
thought are you are you guys comfortable
with that
this is a war against christ keeps
getting smaller against intellectualism
there's a war
war against rational behavior and we're
not even aware of it
wow he's like mafias what kind of an
example are we setting
the problem with america is that because
of cultural imperialism we are
literally teaching the rest of the world
how to think what to wear
the kardashians are lying to you culture
used to be the backbone of the
resistance dude he's starting to look
like the dude from beetlejuice with the
tiny head yeah
seeks to appeal to our primal urge is
our base need
we're now in there he looks like the uh
the koopa troopers from the mario
because the revolution will not be
revolution will not be televised
only you can bring about the revolution
by taking it to the street
keep resisting yeah the frogs his the
froggies
you [ __ ] idiots you absolute [ __ ]
morons
god damn it i hate you so much when you
do this [ __ ] chat i hate it
so [ __ ] much you're like 12 years old
[Music]
[Applause]
oh no he has to take it too far this
ammo guy
[Music]
thank you for watching i will have more
soon i have reawakens
i think that was dark souls music at the
end right now
are you guys ready for this jordan
peterson one because you're gonna have
to buckle up for this one bro
it bloom it blew me away this should be
entered into cannes film festival
short animation yeah short animation
probably i'm tired of like pixel
like pixar like oh there's a little duck
on a [ __ ]
uh a little duck who doesn't have
feathers and he's got to figure out a
way to fit in without feathers it's like
shut the [ __ ] up this is what i want
jordan peterson having an existential
crisis from overcoming a
like a a benzo addiction this is real
[ __ ] right here
where's the awards for this type of
thing
okay watch this i don't know if you guys
know the jordan peterson lore
he i'll give you a little background in
case you don't know
he got the he got addicted to like xanax
or i don't know which specific drug but
it was like a benzo related to xanax i
think valium or something i don't know
something like that one of those kinds
of drugs and he went to um
for some reason he went to russia to get
some special treatment
um and his daughter
was uh
like i'm trying to be respectful but
vladimir putin
he went to russia and his daughter went
like partying around
europe while he was like was he in a
coma
i was just he they put him in a
medically induced coma i believe
oh my god as part of his recovery
jesus so like she was just traveling
around europe having a good time and
then meanwhile they've been on
like this all meat diet where they only
eat meat
and uh that's kind of the starting point
of this animation so
it was a pretty chaotic moment i would
think in the peterson uh
yeah people are saying the benzo
withdrawal is the worst you can go
through yeah i believe that man
apparently he was hitting benzo super
hard
um and so obviously he was like super
addicted to that
and i know yeah benzos can really mess
you up man
so he so you know and then i don't know
what's the deal with this all meat diet
i don't know how anyone thinks that's a
good idea like that you
he claims you know jordan was claiming
he went a little off the deep end for me
i know we had him on the show a bunch of
times back back back in the day
but this whole raw meat thing that was
where you drew the line
well
[Laughter]
yeah now that i've been a vegan for one
day
oh yeah ethan's vegan as of this morning
yeah i'm vegan for
not as of this morning as of yesterday
morning oh okay i'm sorry
well you didn't mention when i asked
about my achievement okay i'm sorry
we're 24 hours in
we're over 24 hours they're vegan
jeff benzos people are saying
vetan so anyway um yeah i don't
understand the whole meat diet
apparently he goes i was on
antidepressants
and i just started eating meat and all
my problems went away
but then you'll notice in here he says
well i had one little sip of apple cider
existential dread for a month which
doesn't really make sense to me
not a doctor obviously but anyway here
it is
here it is for all in all of its
splendor for you to enjoy your father
will have to remain in his coma for
several more months
we'll be feeding him pure meat through a
tube just like you
asked in the meantime let's go
party all over europe
when people think of happiness or
pursuing happiness the first thing they
think of is
well it's a pretty selfish desire i want
to be happy for me i mean after all who
wants to be
unhappy but i'm here to tell you that in
fact happiness is far
far far more than a selfish desire
is this guy a prager you guys that is
that's dennis
that's the man himself okay i wasn't
sure but they're like the conservative
like
uh they're just like yeah they're a
uh content farm
uh to uh educate the youth of america to
become it's like hitler youth basically
for uh young conservatives
i don't know sure let's discover that
is a very very altruistic
endeavor yes indeed we have a moral
obligation
happy people make the world better
unhappy people tend to make the world
worse there's a scene in pinocchio where
geppetto wishes on
a star right and what it means is he
lifts up his eyes
beyond the horizon to something
transcendent and so he lifts his body so
good
looking what i want
[Music]
what what i want more than anything else
is that my creation will become a
genuine
individual right it sits at home does he
really cry over pinocchio analogies
jordan peterson cries over the drop of a
hat man i've i've
seen i've seen so many images that's
going to be
amazing to drop tears over uh pinocchio
as a
he's he's a cry he's a big old cry baby
he's a little great baby
he's a real boy wrote gesture because
it's so unlikely
and that catalyzes the puppets
transformation into a real
being and we start as puppets
and so the trick is to get rid of your
goddamn strings
i want to be like you mr
peterson please tell me
how to live i want to get into this
because this is a
i think this is a fascinating thing with
you personally that your diet
um you're on this carnivore diet now
this is what i mean what's fascinating
to me is i haven't heard any negative
stories about people doing this
well i have a negative story okay okay
when we
restricted our diet and then ate
something we weren't supposed to the
reaction was
absolutely catastrophic but it's so what
did you switch to
um well the worst response we had some
apple cider that had sulfites in it and
that was really not good like i was done
for a month
you were done for a month oh yeah it
took me up for a month it was awesome
apple cider like what was it what was it
doing oh it
it produced an overwhelming sense of
impending doom
you know as someone who doesn't have
experience in
you know psychology or whatever but i
find it extraordinarily unlikely that a
sip of apple cider can produce
feelings of existential doom impending
doom for a month
i mean that seems like
you're not looking in the right place dr
peterson
to explain the dread you're feeling you
know
for a month and probably either he was
withdrawing from his drugs or
uh well he he said he went off his
medicine because the meat cured him
maybe it's the meat i don't know man
maybe it's ever
i don't know
but careful with that apple cider guys
it's apparently a harder drug than lsd
people are saying yeah for sure you have
a bad trip on
apple cider you never come back
[Music]
[Music]
to the president he's with us he's for
us if you love
birds you'd never want to walk under a
window because it's a very sad
and sad oh that was alex jones
[Music]
it's temple right
[Music]
[Applause]
i said certified seven days a week
i
[Music]
the destroyer of worlds bro this is come
on
love the bloodborne music oh is it
bloodborne music [ __ ]
cider see i played that oh yeah i didn't
sleep that that much wait what i didn't
sleep for 25 days
i didn't sleep at all oh my god oh yeah
and this is from
[ __ ] cider from science that's what
we thought yeah the last time i took a
sip of uh
apple cider i woke up in uh russia
without a spleen it's crazy
i just had one sip too
you got to be careful it's the hardest
drug around also that whole scene at the
end is uh
a reference to berserk did you ever go
back and watch the other series
oh the original one no you i mean
look again i don't know where to watch
it i don't know what the hell i'm
talking about
you need to wake up dr peterson
my master please wake up
for us we are so lost without
you
yeah his daughter wrote a book about the
carnivore diet
what is natural must be right eat your
meat
and worship night stand up straight
listen carefully accept you wake up
[Music]
oh my god you guys clean your room
pray to god obey your lords with 12
news this is [ __ ] crazy
yeah no it's unbelievable
[Music]
think of all the cash think of all the
sins
don't
[Music]
it's almost done you have to watch this
stand up
that pulls you together and strengthens
you jimmy cricket is the real master
here
he pulls all the strings
didn't he wake up and re and then he he
made another book 12 more steps
oh i don't know yeah he wrote another
one called 12 more steps when he woke up
and it's like is now the time and i
think that's we learned a lot
the cow was like 12 more steps come on
uh you can fact check that you're dead
he wakes up and there's a [ __ ] stake
in front of him dude i'm not i'm
i'm not seeing him oh he wrote 12 more
steps i swear i mean maybe
oh come on i'm not finding it
really 12 hours more rules
for life oh yeah more roast
i swear he wrote another book oh he
totally did yeah
oh it's called beyond order oh it just
came out earlier this year yeah he came
out and oh the subtitle
is 12 more rules he he came out of his
[ __ ] coma
and well he learned a lot well why
doesn't he make one of the rules just
eat meat if it's that big of a deal
like forget all the other well we do we
know the rules oh here they are
just eat meat let's see i'm reading i'm
reading the 12 more rules
uh okay i'm not
saying anything about meat in here well
i mean it seems like a big deal
yeah kind of sidestepped that one on the
meat show
so um that that video blew my [ __ ]
mind
yeah i know that's insane it's out it
captivated me last night i was going
through that guy's channel
because i saw the crowder one and i was
like what is this person who
is he this this person is so talented oh
my god
of a sick mind dude
okay so let's look did you find any
interesting rules you can share with us
uh no uh none of them are interesting at
all
actually well i would add don't eat meat
and or eat meat only and don't do benzos
you know hell yes instead of like being
like the
lobster or whatever much more tangible
rule to follow
because i'll you know anyway let's talk
about the david dobrik thing and then
let's talk about
xqc okay now david dobre
dubrick dubrick i got a message from
mark
rubio legend friend of the show
absolute [ __ ] g he goes yo
and by the way i have permission to
share all this so don't don't stress
david someone from david's camp gets a
hold of mark's
touring manager and they want to come
to his after party at lollapalooza
he says dude i'm in a weird situation
about to play the lollapalooza after
party and apparently david dobrik and
his crew want to come see the show
should i say no
i said i'm not letting him in [ __ ] that
dude
he said i rejected them and we had the
entire the entire house
of blues cheering and so i asked him for
a clip
and he provided by the way
but i was like what happened um
so apparently
uh yeah him and his whole crew are down
there in lollapalooza
and i guess i mean look he's still got a
bunch of clout i mean he's david dobrik
dubrick it's fun it's just it's amazing
how people can do anything and nobody
cares about anything ever anymore
um i mean the guy did this heinous act
that he never really reckoned with it
either i mean
the man put out a video
of a girl being essayed
i mean it's just crazy
but anyway mark said no [ __ ] him and the
legend brought got me a video of it
happening
so although there's no real world
repercussions i mean people like trillar
are lining up to sponsor them triller
was like
ryan kevin i was like wait you s you
filmed someone getting essayed my guy
but at least there's people like mark
keeping him honestly
i hope he didn't get in david [ __ ] that
[Applause]
guy
i don't like pieces of [ __ ] like that
into my show
damn mark is such a gee he's such a
legend
we love mark rubio on this show folks
he's such a nice guy he's a great guy
what can i say i mean damn
and i was like you know i get it if you
want because david's like
it's flattering right someone david
dover super famous he wants to come and
see your show and like i mean clout you
up or whatever
so i get it i was like listen i totally
get it if you want to let him in like
that's that's a
potentially like big thing for your
opportunity right or what i don't know
to get a shout out from dubrick from
dubrick but
you know mark's such a g he goes [ __ ]
that guy
don't let him in and on top of it i'm
going to say it
on this mic [ __ ] that guy don't let him
in
cheers from the crowd av your thoughts
the first time i met mark i opened the
door for him and uh
i hugged him and i told him big fan he
goes i'm a big fan of you too a.b
and i thought that was the coolest thing
like you hugged him he hugged me he
hugged all of us yeah he hugged all of
us okay
you made it sound like you went in for a
hug on prom no no no no no i held it
one of our guests like that no i held
the door for him and he came and gave me
a hug and said i'm a big fan nice guy he
really is a 10 out of 10 guy
like he's out of 10. yeah yeah he's a
good dude
oh you have some i mean 9 out of 10. why
are you holding this
perfect 10 out of 10. i think mark rubio
he's an ineffable he's an ineffable
being he's he's
divine not on a scale of one to god yeah
what is a ten it's a perfect score
he's not a perfect guy he's human i'm
giving him a nine out of ten he's nobody
said he's a demigod
we said he's uh you did by giving him a
ten out of ten he's the loser
man that guy who said jesus christ was a
10. a lot of people didn't
we have different perceptions of what a
10 is then because a 10 out of 10 to me
is a perfect score
he's kind of a do you even have any
fault like you better back up your nine
like do you even know him well enough to
say he's a nine
well i just i i i mean we all have flaws
we all have
yeah but whatever what's wrong you have
flaws dan is saying
no human is a ten that's all he's saying
that's all he may not have flaws
and for you to assume that he's not a
perfect person
wait i'm sorry i'm just trying to come
up with a reason i don't know when was
that
a reason to deduct points i don't know
he's
ripped i'm just [ __ ] dude any
musician that can improv like that like
[ __ ] dude he's just not a no no nobody
on this earth is a 10 out of 10. that's
all i'm saying
so according to dan you can't be a 10 to
10 if you're short no you can't be a 10
out of 10 if you're not
the son of god jesus christ my personal
savior say jesus christ was even
attended
then well that's blasphemy okay
maybe he's the son of god too much
mark's a 10 out of 10 guy he is a 10 out
of 10 dude thank you zach
so that was fun i i don't know if i had
more to say about that no i mean
just really cool maybe he's a 9.5 out of
10 even
maybe he's an 11 out of 10. i'll accept
nine points mathematically impossible
i'll except 9.9 repeating yeah i'm just
you know i don't have about nine though
that's insulting i think
i think it's you know putting too much
pressure on a person to give them a ten
out of ten
that's not a standard that anybody even
mark can live in nine repeating
sure sure all right rate ethan
don't rape me i didn't brady
i didn't ask to be rated i don't want to
know
on the spot come on do it no i want to
keep my job yeah
yeah and i want you to keep your job too
okay so you know there's one other thing
i want to talk about here today before
we
um play our video games
we have the half-life vr part two coming
up here
uh xqc is making uh
waves
because he is i'm a little confused
about this you know
um he got
a dmc people are saying i'm a one out of
ten thank you everybody
well who would be a one out of ten like
hitler would be like a one out of ten
guy
yeah yeah evil is a ten out of ten yeah
even ela oh stop it
you're such a [ __ ] hater right now
yeah you are
forget the dan the lover sound bite that
is gone it's done
it's gone yeah you are being an ultimate
hater right now
bro it's not a hate i'm giving him a
nine out of a 10.
i mean that's a good no before bringing
it down the whole conversation was like
he's a 10 out of 10 guy and you're
bringing the energies down you're just
you're putting too much pressure on the
man i feel like he would appreciate
what i'm saying yeah calling him short
well you were pressuring me to come up
with a reason i don't know
oh well what the [ __ ] anyway
let's move on so xqc
i'd love to get him on if he's down you
guys ask him if he wants to come on i
don't know
so he got a dmca no apparently on twitch
people they're really cracking down
on dmca and the olympics
in general has always been very
aggressive which i get let's be honest i
mean the olympics like they
they pay like billions of dollars for
the rights to stream it
and you know it can't be easy to recoup
your costs these days especially with
cable
and the ratings this year i've been like
disastrous so i'm sure i haven't heard
anyone talking about the olympic
you know i've been watching it and also
it's like in japan so i mean
it's on at like 3 a.m i mean
it's kind of a rough thing i i'm not
gonna lie i've been enjoying watching
the olympics though i put it on at night
you know people they're rowing they're
skating they're swimming
you know whatever
anyway so he got the thing is so when
you get a dmca
on twitch you also get banned apparently
that whole system seems so ass backwards
the dmca by the way
this this was his fourth band by the way
for dmca
i don't know if they're all dmca related
but it says this was his fourth one
well apparently he got he got
immediately reinstated though right love
there's a slight difference you can get
your vod dmc8 which is normal
very normal yeah uh what he got though
was a live band which is very unusual
and
um or a live dmca sorry and that made
him
go banned instantly right apparently
it's a different cold down like a band
cooldown of like
normal tos cold ons yeah i mean
again we'll do it live yeah it makes
sense why it would be rare i mean it's
hard to catch someone in the
act versus when the vaude is up
now again once again i understand their
need to protect their rights
the problem with the dmca is that it's
very much like shoot first
um like kill them first and let god sort
them out kind of mentality
it's like how can you make a distinction
on the spot
that what he's doing is in fair use and
there's just not enough consequences for
people who take down videos like that
because when you interfere with
somebody's business in that way
without making a distinction if it's
fair use or not
is as damaging to their business as
someone ripping off your content
so it's like your ip rights shouldn't
supersede
my ip rights you know and
you know and on the other end twitch is
also the fact that they're banning
people in that regard
is pretty wild too you know i've always
been a champion of uh
my whole career of fair use i'm
currently in my second lawsuit to
protect fair use
and i feel like i am somewhat i mean
obviously i'm not a lawyer but i feel
like i have as good of a grasp of it as
you can um at this point
according to a b a dmca bands normally
last for 24 hours he was banned for two
days however which is double that is
that right
i guess it's well known not to [ __ ] with
the olympics
but i'm first of all i'm curious one
well anyway this story get big because
apparently he's counter
suing them but then i read some tweets
from his attorney
that says they're just disputing it
which isn't a counter lawsuit which
isn't a big deal i dispute [ __ ] every
day so i'm cut so i'm trying to create
some clarity on this situation
and also i want to watch uh
his reaction to determine if
it's transformative or not we're gonna
blur out the
actual olympics because obviously
i'm not trying to relive the same fate
he did
but i'm more i'm more interested in his
reaction anyway
to say like it was this a uh a
transformative
uh reaction because right now
they are doing this whole media thing i
have a problem with this lawyer i'm
gonna say that right now and i'm gonna
get into that
his lawyer the video game attorney um
was our first attorney to represent us
in the lawsuit against matt haas many
years ago
and um uh
he is a horrible attorney
that royally screwed us and um
the fact that he's handling this makes
me very very nervous
um
we almost sued them for malpractice mar
the next attorneys we got which were
extremely
competent were just outraged at what he
handled this so ryan ryan morrison is
out there saying that it's fair use and
i
actually am afraid that ryan is
misleading him
and so i want to make my own distinction
i haven't watched this
and i want to watch this and uh see for
myself because the thing is
that if ryan represents him in a bad
case
not only is xuc going to get screwed
with time and money and
liability but he can actually set back
the work that
we've done like if we get a bad ruling
against fair use that can screw
everybody and so
what's up i just wanted dan's take on
something
and so the thing hold up the blurred
foot no we should talk about it because
we don't want to get screwed he pulled
up
the blurred footage it's i don't know if
that's blurred enough to be honest
uh i mean did you see it yeah no i see
it
i mean it should be let's like all right
i i see what you mean i mean it could
even be blacked out for all i'm worried
about but i mean like
how are you gonna say you can't possibly
say that this is a market substitute
like if you try to take this i will
[ __ ]
now i'm joining xqc screw said
[Music]
it's like blurred it's muted i'm talking
over it it's like a meta analysis i mean
i don't even give a [ __ ] about what he's
watching
and just to clarify this isn't the
moment that he got banned this is just
the only
footage we could even find from that
stream yeah it's okay i just want an
example of the kind of commentary he's
providing
so this guy ryan morrison who's
representing him very much concerns me
um this guy botched our first lawsuit
so badly the video game attorney
they botched it so badly we raised a
bunch of money by the way
philly d raised a bunch of money for us
and
put it into like and then it was ryan's
idea
to put it into uh to make a non-profit
organization
right and then but it turns out after we
make the non-profit
you can't [ __ ] make a non-profit
for the purpose of supporting yourself
that's [ __ ]
illegal it's called fraud
like the whole point of the money that
was this is all ancient history was like
a hundred thousand dollars
we're talking about and um at the time
it was like an
extraordinary it is an extraordinary
money but at the time that was like more
money than we have ever
made and we needed it desperately to pay
for this lawsuit
and so he was like let's set up this
non-profit and put the money in there
and obviously any attorney should know
that a non-profit can't you can't make a
non-profit to pay for your own [ __ ]
so the money almost got stuck there
because it would be illegal for us to
use it
so not only was and then at the same
time as tying up our money and
potentially committing fraud
they were fighting the lawsuit in the
dumbest way imaginable
they were instead of actually arguing
the merit of the
of the lawsuit saying that this is fair
use they were trying to argue that their
copyright registration was invalid
over some technicality
and it's like that just makes you look
so weak as i talk to my other attorneys
so like this argument was so pointless
uh and so weak it makes you look weak
because you're not arguing the merits
and the thing is even if you get it
thrown out on a technicality
he can just register and sue you again
and so
it was going so sideways that at a point
they even encouraged us to consider
settling [ __ ] paying off matt haas
which is the whole reason why we were
fighting it to begin with and at that
point we're like
this isn't working we went got a new
lawyer fired them and our new lawyers
who
won the lawsuit for us and handled
things the professional way
were aghast at the way that ryan handled
it
ryan and his partner handled it and even
considered
suing for malpractice because of the way
they they handled it and especially the
way they set up this non-profit
because we had to like in the end we had
to pay more attorneys to petition
the attorneys general of new york to
explain what happened so we could get
the money out
so we had to pay a bunch of attorneys a
bunch of fees just to get the money back
it was that it was such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
show
and i'm and i'm not the thing is there
was not experienced attorneys
and so it doesn't surprise me at the
time what really was [ __ ] up
is that he didn't say i'm not
experienced enough in this
and reference me to a real attorney
say listen we can do these one things so
that's what i'm afraid of xqc right now
is that
ryan is out there saying this is fair
use we're fighting it and not
i'm not i'm not a [ __ ] media attorney
and i'm not equipped to deal with this
like i've held my tongue on the sky for
so long but now it's come to this point
where
i see him in a position to cause even
more damage and
um i really think that this is a
dangerous
place for everyone to be when he's being
represented by this guy who really
doesn't know what he's doing and as far
as i'm aware actually doesn't understand
fair use at all
so let's watch this and make a
determination i haven't seen this yet
she will come on here with nobody out
and a run this isn't blurred enough you
guys
well that's what i agree cam you gotta
you you just black
just like um pixelate it more
how about just don't even show that just
zoom in on xqc's box because that's what
we care about right
so you don't even need to show the
footage no you don't need to i mean you
could just block black it out
oh you want me to zoom in on his box
yeah i can do that here i'll just do
this
drag that i was saying if your screen
outside oh yeah there you go i'll just
do this
but perfect okay here we go there you go
this explains it
the style of play in the past it's been
the u.s power not as much power for
japan
that's almost flipped it's flipped bro
oh [ __ ]
is history in the making this is cortez
23 years old first woman
in the majors
[Applause]
so what is he watching like a
compilation he sounds like
he's showing like a meme like a baseball
meme
oh it's just a meme yeah was he watching
like unusual videos or something or what
happened
[Music]
so it was two games put together the the
last part of the clip was from a
2016 um world series game
um that that's what he was laughing at
okay um the first half of the clip is
from the olympics
but then he goes over to another clip
that
so is this right so i love i don't know
if you're familiar is this kind of
representative of the commentary he
provides throughout
oh i i can't answer that i never got the
chance to watch maybe the chat notes
because
right now i just see him laughing and
obviously
i don't know what he watched or if that
was transformative but like
i'm not seeing someone saying need
longer context
yeah i think a lot of people some people
are saying that's the entire stream
but i think the the point is
the problem is guys it's hard to find
the actual
clip because it's been hunted down by
the olympics you know
but the point is is that
obviously what i'm seeing now there's no
way this is transformative
but i don't have the full context but my
point is is that
this is not a clean cut case of [ __ ]
fair use right
like it's just not i'd love to talk to
him i don't know if people are there
i'm very worried about him
being in the hands of ryan morrison i
really am
yeah right now if our chat maybe we want
to
ask him asmin gold commented on it as
well
defending him he so i don't know if i
have the whole context but
people just need to be really afraid
because
fair use covers a lot but you don't want
to go
fight the wrong fight on this [ __ ] you
really don't
you really don't you know
and like if they if the olympics wants
to do a dmca
i'm not sure those are the people you
want to go up against and especially
with this
when this is your [ __ ] uh
commentary
i'm sorry i just want to correct
something i said i said it was a two-day
ban initially it was is what i'm saying
but then it got reduced
to five hours yeah that's what i thought
i remember he got
someone said ryan morrison has helped
has experienced so much now since you
left dealt with him
they've helped countless esports oregon
big streamers yeah he might have
experience with likes
with like contracts and stuff but i'm
just telling you he's not a media
litigator and he has no [ __ ] idea
what he's doing
when it comes to fair use and litigating
these cases
if you have a contract you want to go
over with them for esports cool
do that this is a whole different beast
that's why there's specialties there you
know what i mean there's
there's specialties in law people
specialize
oh someone's saying xqc has h3 nuked
whatever that means
anyway um
so i i it's hard to know it's hard to
know because we can't find more but
obviously
people are saying h3 is a banned um
phrase in his chat
yeah i don't think he was very happy
with the the exchange that we had with
now last time
xqc didn't really go that well xqc
banned h3 there's a there's a uh
headline
well actually you know what i talked to
him in the dms i warned him about ryan
the minute i saw he was representing him
and he said uh
oh he acknowledged my my what i said so
he knows
okay so there's that there you go that's
good yeah
other people saying it's not banned
people are saying he's trolling
trolling you might want to watch what
he's uh doing right now he's
listening to the top 700 music
i'm gonna get i'm gonna get we're both
gonna get banned to fight
turn him on he's going to take the whole
twitch platform down with him
yeah let's chain reaction take the whole
thing down
no oh i can't watch this
i can't watch this i can't watch this
stop that's what's up the music
what the [ __ ] is this
listen i said what it was i've seen it
listen i've seen his unusual memes edits
i've seen him react to stuff
like in my in my opinion i'm not gonna
say if it's fair use or not obviously
that's a distinction that a judge will
make
or a jury will make after weighing all
the considerations of fair use
but if i was uh in his shoes or his
attorney
i would not be eager to go up against
the olympics with what he has
right yeah and also losing would be a
terrible precedent
and could harm everybody
so anyway he made a video about it so
let's watch this let's see
i didn't go live for a while i think
it's what happened
holy [ __ ] i forgot i didn't yet actually
kind of interesting what happened
so i hope we don't get lost into like um
legal terms or whatever
okay so if you're if you're like um
hello
i'll lower your andy can you have to
settle down and wait till the story
finishes okay
so basically
what had happened is did how do you say
this [ __ ]
what has had had happened i have to be
careful
okay because this is like some legal
[ __ ] so
i kind of have to go about what i say on
stream okay kind of
okay but basically okay i was doing the
olympics
and i was doing some react content right
and then i got striked okay and normally
strikes don't get you bend but because
it's a live strike
they ban you so there's no like further
damage or whatever
i would assume it's money to do it and
normally it's 24 hours
but for some reason this time for me it
was two-day band
but this ban doesn't affect my bands
though being banned for this
doesn't make you banned like uh like if
you show the titty on stream
it's just so you don't like continue
[ __ ] up
excuse me so it's not even a band yeah i
didn't do it it's
basically counted as a strike but then i
looked at it
and i was like dude so i talked to my
team whatever
i'm like yo guys can you do anything
about this like two days sounds like a
crazy amount of time
for this and like oh you know we have
like option a
option b option c whatever and then i'm
like um
the dumb option or not
they present me the options whatever and
one of the options looked kind of cool
it looked kind of fun and i was like you
know dude let's go with this one
right so we did instead is that we
issued
and we call it a counter claim
which is pretty ballsy it's not so this
is the other thing where they're making
like a big hubbub
this is something ryan does too where he
tries to turn everything into pr
is that a counter claim is not ballsy
i've done it a
bazillion times it literally is not
ballsy it's
it's it's routine it's it's actually
just totally routine
if somebody dmca's you you can basically
say
i'm gonna restore the content and if you
want me to remove it
you have to sue me and but the thing is
that doing a counter claim will restore
your content but it doesn't change the
legal status
of the infringement they can sue you at
any time
the dmca is just a remedy available to
copyright holders
so that they can remove it without
having to sue you so
you know um yeah if you do a um
a counter a counter claim or counter
notification
um it's it's it's absolutely routine i
mean
it happens every day thousands of times
on youtube
we do it all the time it really isn't uh
it really isn't anything i mean
obviously the thing is like if if the
olympics does a dmca on you
and you just say okay fine [ __ ] it then
the likelihood that they're going to
come sue you is very low because you
complied the
content is done they don't want to sue
you over that it's pointless you know
but if you count if you if you do
counter
claim then you you get the content
restored obviously it does increase the
chances of being sued because now their
only remedy
to get the video down is to sue you but
the likely the likeliness of them suing
you is extremely low
extremely low
so it's not really that big of a deal
now if i was them though
i would probably look at that and say
this is better off down you know
uh that that would be my decision in
that case
so what a counter claim does is that
they the mca
so they strike me and instead of saying
oh
i [ __ ] up it's kind of like saying
like no i'm right
kind of i think it's like saying it this
is
transformative content this is um
fair use and this is not
what you guys claim it is so we counter
claimed it
so that does is that that removes a
strike but we're fighting back
type of thing and if this
if this like escalates this is it's so
routine it's literally built in
like in youtube you can file a counter
claim just through the software by
typing in your name
and clicking a few boxes like you don't
even need to pay you don't need a lawyer
to do a
counter claim it's like so stupid
well it'll get crazy the problem is we
as content creators like as much as we
talk about fair use
we also have to acknowledge that
copyright does exist
and that right holders have rights too
because the minute that we start
over
the minute we start overestimating what
fair use is
is when we lose all of our [ __ ]
all of our rights right because the
minute that you just start turning into
jinx reacts and laughing at jokes and
calling it transformative
then we're all it's gonna [ __ ] us all
over because let's face it they have
their rights we have to acknowledge
their rights
if we want them to acknowledge our
rights and so the fact that him and his
his lawyers even like entertaining this
as an
option like a good option is crazy to me
based on what i've seen
based on what i've seen okay
it could be that he offered more
commentary at a different point in the
video that transformed it
i don't know crazy what i'm saying it'll
get crazy
it'll get [ __ ] crazy crazy we're
talking
crazy crazy yeah ryan's just ryan is
literally just
telling you [ __ ] it's not gonna get
crazy
but my lawyer said it
i cringe so much when i know that ryan's
his lawyer after what i've been through
with that guy
it's crazy crazy but
um
it could cost millions
xqcl so what it does is stop playing
with me your line
so what it does hold that do it
well because i j time it is fair use
and
it's whatever dude i guess i don't think
i might do much because it's like some
legal [ __ ] and i don't want it to you
know you baby don't leave us
like that again sexy game the [ __ ]
i think this was the end this was the
move to do it
and i think that that that was the
correct call because otherwise it's
really done
five months um no i
and them truly believe it is actually
fairies and transformative
and we have a we have actually grounds
to stand on
i don't know where because i thought i
had i had grounds to stand on the law so
we won and ryan and his partner were
suggesting we settle
so because they had [ __ ] the case up
so bad
to be fair we saw a one-minute clip i
know maybe there are other parts
where he was pausing and you know
offering a lot of commentary and
what i saw was not fair use i can say
that you know
with uh i can say that uh with uh
that one clip yeah but again
again it's fair use is considered you
consider the whole
clip and the context of everything
so i don't know i just where i'm that
the thing is when i
went from ryan morrison to a real law
firm the difference is [ __ ] night and
day because i never worked with an
attorney so i was easily seduced by this
guy
but once you go to a real law firm then
you see what it's actually like to be
represented by a real attorney
i'm just scared for him and a lot of it
too i missed you
and if things are gonna get crazy they
will get crazy but i i generally think
they were right about this
well regardless the chance of them
actually pursuing anything is like
like close to zero so you know the risk
is is very very very very low like i do
counter
notifications every day although i'm
more confident that my
i'm confident my content that is fair
use i just don't trust wait you're
you're
not convinced that the olympics are
going to go after them well
like that they'll actually take up no
i'm not i is the chance is very low
because it's not really a market
substitute
you know i think the the problem one of
the different i've just heard that the
olympics are notoriously
litigious about this kind of stuff so
but i
that's just when i was researching it
this morning apparently i have a
reputation for going after yeah they
might
they might and they they certainly don't
want like especially when it's a big
public thing and they're like trying to
make an example
i mean yeah they might you know in
normal situations i wouldn't really be
concerned about it
the big factor with fairies is is it a
market substitute
so if the olympics is looking to sue
they're looking for where the damages
are people watching the stream instead
of ours
but then again statutory damages for
infringing on the copyright is 250 000
so they sue them for 250 000 but they
couldn't assume for more than that i
mean it would cost
more it would cost each party more to
pay their lawyers
than it would to whatever the
the damages would be you know what i
mean um
so it's entirely possible that they
could sue looking for some kind of
settlement or just to make a point not
to [ __ ] with the olympics
um it's not the olympics it's nbc
universal slash comcast morons oh i
didn't see the morons before i started
reading your comments so but they're
they're the ones that paid a
billions of dollars right they pay the
licensing fee also i'm banning that guy
so see you yeah
um here's ryan morrison's tweet about it
that when i saw this oh and other people
are saying they're wrong it is the ioc
so i'm glad i uh
dude when i saw this i panicked i'm
telling you because
this guy just gives me anxiety bro i'm
telling you it was the worst
situation you could ever have with an
attorney
he says about xqc we see countless dmcas
come in for our clients
and we normally advise not to counter
due to the extreme risks
okay we discussed all the option with
felix and he's confident as are we
that the content in question was fair
use as such he made the call to take a
stand
when you counter dmca the rights
holder's only option is to sue you as
such felix is taking on an incredible
risk
to stand up for what is right here that
said do not counter your own dmca
without speaking to an attorney
yeah unfortunately ryan barely counts as
an attorney so that's why i'm afraid for
him
not sure he's getting good legal counsel
we are not suing anyone we expect the i
o
c to make the right decision and let
this die if that is the case is a done
deal and nothing more to the story
however we're ready to defend felix no
matter how they choose to proceed yeah i
mean
again i wish i had the full context to
say but based on what i saw i'm very
worried about this being fair use
and i'm not i have no faith at all in
the um
council of uh ryan morrison so i don't
know
i mean if you guys have more clips i'd
love to see it i don't know where we
looked everywhere we couldn't find it
and of course this is always what you'd
like to see your lawyer say i've learned
so much about dmc and fair use today
from reddit and twitter
he's probably kidding right but yeah
he's being surprised basically based on
my experience with them
you might be watching this being like
wow take a note yeah he's taking notes
yeah i can't emphasize to you guys how
much this guy [ __ ] me and almost lost
thus that fair use case he really did
this guy makes me understand why people
hate lawyers
my new lawyers are amazing
ugh
yeah i wish i could i wish there was a
way for me to find more
and make more of a judgment if it's um
yeah his name is video game attorney and
he might be great with contract
i know he works with like streamers on
contracts and stuff
he might be great at that he might be
great
that's why people specialize in law it's
[ __ ] up for him not to refer him
to an actual [ __ ] litigator that
handles
media
that's what pissed me off in retrospect
is that he didn't
own up to the fact that he was not
experienced enough to handle our case
because he wanted the clout
he wanted the attention and so he took
on a case he was not qualified to take
on
and i didn't know better
oh there's a video game attorney uh
comment on live stream phil
yeah i don't know if you guys have
i don't anyway that's about all i have
to say about that
people are saying video game attorney
commented on some live stream fail
threads
yeah he he that's kind of how he made
his whole
career is commenting on reddit
i mean it's kind of weird reddit lawyer
that's what he was a reddit lawyer and
then
people started you know
started actually referring to him for
[ __ ] and the thing is
that whatever i'm not here to
just dedicate [ __ ] on on him i just
i just want to give my two cents on the
situation
and i just want to caution xqc to be to
be careful
because he laughs now about losing like
spending millions of dollars but a
lawsuit
is going through a lawsuit bro it's not
just money you have to understand that
the money is one aspect you have to get
deposed
you have to get discovered they can
request documents from
you that you would never want another
person to see you have to go
sit in a in a little [ __ ]
cubicle with the opposing lawyer for
eight hours as they grill you
and potentially other people in your
life too you could even get deposed
twice
if the judge thinks it's necessary the
whole
everything surrounding an attorney is
absolutely [ __ ] horrendous
or a lawsuit so i found another clip
from his stream
oh you did that oh great it's not edited
so make sure to sue me okay great thank
you love good job
i found the comments on uh live
streaming thank you chad
fantastic work guys okay so so what i'm
going to do here because
i don't want to even make any con oh
that's train wrecks hello
um how can it doesn't let me uh zoom in
maybe
when i full screen go out to the right
so you only show his face
if that makes sense yeah hold on let me
try this because it lets me zoom
so how's this can everyone see kind of
yeah all right so this is perfect here
let me just
let me just tiny box it i don't even
want
i don't care about what's going on on
the screen i just want to see
his uh his take right
okay here we go four x one hundred
united states
[Applause]
15 meters look at that i don't need to
circle that guy right now
you know he's going to jump on that
first 15. nobody has the speed
petey like they're then caleb got one of
the greatest starts in history
in all sports right out of the gates
caleb dressel trying to build that lead
for the united states russia
a half second behind and so how do you
use
doping in archery make some noise
against dressle
but it's dressel leading the way that's
like taking steroids
to pass the [ __ ] math test but not
much well this is what they need they
need the lead but dressel was really
going to hopefully get them a little bit
biggerly they have really closed the gap
here
all right so blake perroni goes in as
caleb dressel
makes his tokyo debut france i mean
so x 100 yeah okay so there's a certain
there's a there's one point in his favor
which is that he's making like a meta
analysis of the russian team being
banned
so he is making so he's adding
commentary in that degree
but the part that really concerns me is
that he's not even watching the clip
he's reading
chat and the clip is playing in the
background
and i feel like the olympics would have
a pretty good argument to say that
it's not transformative and and it's a
replacement actually
for that you could watch this as a
replacement
to i could argue that it's basically a
watch party
like you have it up and it's a bunch of
people watching it together
the main component of fair use is that
it doesn't
substitute the original which means you
wouldn't go
watch xqc to watch the olympics there's
no way that anyone wanting to watch the
olympics would come
watch xqc talk over the olympics you you
would just go watch it on your tv
but in this case because he's so small
and because the olympics is so big
because he's just reading chat
and and not always commentary
commentating
pausing stuff like that that there is a
very good argument for them to say that
this
is a market substitute like you said dan
i think a watch party is a good analogy
and so there this is not a clean cut
case here
i'm not going to say that he has like a
horrible chance of prevailing
but i would also say that he doesn't he
doesn't necessarily have a great case
here either
you know this would not be an easy this
would be a very difficult path forward
for them
to rogan's asking how often do you have
to talk
for it to be fair use there's that's the
thing it's not really a hard and fast
rule extinction of fair use is made
in totality and consideration of all the
four
uh points of fair use okay
the most important one is the uh
is the market substitute and the
transformation
so there's no like there's no
goal post right it's taken in
consideration of everything
and a judge or jury makes a
consideration
with the evidence and as the lawyers
argue it and that's kind of the tricky
thing about it
but in my case like all the lawsuits
that the first lawsuit it was like a
quintessential fair use they said but we
were like
pausing commenting doing
edits there was times when i filled the
whole screen
there's times when it filled the whole
screen
and so every ex every time is a
different
example that needs to be considered
here's another one of him reacting to
what looks like ping-pong
so let's do the same thing here where we
zoom in
okay
not understanding now because they go
they go flying
and the balls go and they have to
counter it
they have to counter the effect right
and if because if they can't and they
just they just hit it normally even if
you
just held up your thing like this and
you let it touch it it would go
just smiling laughing
trying packing that yeah this one's
probably more
this one's more on the fair use side as
he paused it
and he offered commentary you know uh
whatever commentary that was
uh it actually doesn't matter if the
judge even said in my case
it doesn't matter if you think it's
useful or funny or informative or
anything
you know it doesn't matter fair use
isn't there to protect
the those with good intentions or good
commentaries there to protect everybody
um so you know uh this one's probably
more on the side of being fine but again
it's only a 30 second clip
a judge would want to see the whole
stream
they're going to want to see the whole
hour long stream
and analyze that
that's very interesting do you think the
length of these long streams serve as a
asset to these streamers
like in terms of fair use because the
whole stream is totality is about
you know several hours possibly the fact
that whatever they're watching shorter
they get away with
more no i think the judge would would
just they would they would
just um they would just view the
relevant
part of it it would be something to
consider i think i think the
the the defendant in this case sqc's
lawyer could definitely make that
argument that
you know it was just this piece
of the stream for sure yeah it probably
does benefit them a little bit
uh xqc
some of the top comments wasn't he the
attorney that h3 first had and then he
fired yes
it was him
yeah i've never talked about it because
i just didn't i just never wanted to get
into it
wait there was more to that that was the
thread that he responded
so where's his response i just see how
he responded to this comment about me
firing him yes
so just scroll down a little bit oh oh
it's cause this [ __ ] i [ __ ] hate new
reddit
it's so bad so this is interesting
wait the [ __ ] you talking about wait
what i'm not he's responding to
what mclovin said yep that's him i'm not
100 sure but i think what got him fired
is he forgot to file paperwork on time
spot on wasn't us but it was a super
simple fix regardless so didn't cause
any damage thankfully what is he what
are they talking about
i don't know what people kept saying
that he commented
about your case in this thread so i went
and found
his comment and what the [ __ ]
of what i thought i mean you're familiar
with the situation i thought maybe
that was the other firm he switched to
the guy was on vacation when they had to
file paperwork because ethan moved
during the lawsuit
i don't know what anyone's talking about
that is a weird [ __ ] comment from
ryan
what the [ __ ] all right we have more
love's coming through what they reached
so i found a pretty fun
like weird way to watch the stream that
he deleted
yeah or kinda if you go like you can
scrub
over with the mouse you can see that
right
uh so at the 10 hour mark if you press
clip you can actually watch the stream
still
oh yeah so if you make a clip you can
watch what you're editing
is that does that make sense he didn't
mess up but ethan's other attorneys did
no you got [ __ ] fired and they saved
my ass end of story
that's all that happened bro i don't
know what the [ __ ] you're talking about
crazy ass
so okay so then so then is this the
totality of his commentary that we're
watching here
uh love well i'll link to your timestamp
right yeah
so if you click that and well it's a
dumb workaround but if you press click
yeah so wait this is his whole stream
right now
well yeah but it's blocked out for the
part where he watches uh
okay so let's let's see what happens
well
soda makakomi here and uh yeah it gets
taken onto
the back of the net i would say one big
problem that he has and other twitch
streamers has
is that he's in a small box and he never
occupies the whole screen
that is going to be a lot of trouble
because
um because
if the clip is on the screen the whole
time
that is going to cause a lot of trouble
for the defense
like when we fight lawsuits they always
say that
there's lots of pauses where i occupy
the screen the whole time
and you could say like for example the
ryan cavanaugh one that we're dealing
with now with triller
it's like it's like we showed the fight
for let's say i don't remember i'm just
gonna throw numbers out these aren't
accurate it's totally just
untethered it's like we showed the fight
for
one minute 20 seconds of it was
the fight itself 20 seconds of it was
paused
and um 20 seconds was it of me talking
over it
and so the fact that they're
it's on screen the whole time is going
to be a big problem for them
she didn't do it purposely having a look
there just
a neck uh roll and
see out yeah looking to see if suzie
gets disqualified for
it jesus ouchy
suzy and uh kosovo have got so yeah
obviously
saying aochie is not going to transform
anything because that's a parent
if someone got hurt that's a parent from
watching it right that's that's a that's
a uh
that's not a transformative uh
commentary because it doesn't
it it's obvious to everyone watching
that that someone got hurt
well we've been saying confounded by the
the
you know added to the point that he's in
a small box in the corner
um this is bad that's not the way that
you want
any of these contests definitely oh wow
she feels robbed that's that's kind of
weird
wait why why is she not where's she
upset
and kosovo i've got a second gold medal
here
well we've been saying that's not the
way that you want any of these contests
everyone's saying uh he wants to talk
xuc
great i'd love to talk to him uh let me
uh
see if i can get him on the line let's
get them on zoom so that we don't
uh that would be
a similar situation let me uh i would
love to talk to xqc about this
100 percent
um someone says he doesn't wait are you
sure about this people are saying i
don't know it's the chat
no don't do it people are saying
chad is trolling people saying i don't
know well open his chat love you give me
impartial uh oh yeah
i it might have been a troll yeah
no that's my yes chad is being toxic
okay
thank you everybody thank you thank you
yeah i mean look guys
ouchie is not gonna fly it's not gonna
fly
it's just not
the thing is a good attorney will say
listen dude
this is a lot of liability here we
definitely should just
consider ourselves lucky that they only
dmcad us and nothing more
because like i said at the end of the
day we have to acknowledge the rights of
the copyright holders
so that we can do what we do if we just
[ __ ] say everything's fair use then
we become as bad as the people that just
dmca everything you see what i'm saying
again i'm not saying one way or the
other
based on what i saw it's looking very
dangerous situation for him
and just knowing ryan morrison i'm
worried that's all
peace and love peace and love should we
play half-life
oh uh sure
let's do it i okay so now this is i've
been looking forward to this all week we
got
a brand new valve index
if you guys were here last week you'll
notice that we had insane technical
issues
that resulted in us just scrapping the
the last one
um so we got a new one
that's amazing i haven't tried it yet
dan you tried it
yeah i came in over the weekend and set
it up and [ __ ] around with it a little
bit and it's pretty damn cool
also interestingly someone from htc who
makes the vive reached out to us too and
was like yo i want to help you with the
new set so we're going to have the index
and the vive yeah we got to do a little
a b comparison i think so maybe
the next session we'll use the latest uh
live and then we can make a
determination of what we like more
so let's take a quick break just while
we rejigger the set and everything for
the vr
and um i am so excited i am so
excited all right let's uh
actually love this so guys stick around
we're gonna play some half-life
h3 3d 4d experience
we'll be back as soon as we are ready
setting this up so just give us a brief
moment here
we'll be right back thank you peace and
love peace okay
half life alex play through part two
begins now
um i just fell down this hole and that
was not the way to go
interestingly well i hear baddies from
here so
um let's try is this a puzzle
right maybe okay observe your
surroundings a little
we've [ __ ] with this thing before
let's see is this like bait
or he has something in his hand eh oh
[ __ ]
oh do i gotta grab this thing
okay let's see if i can grab it
[Music]
no i could grab that thing i'm assuming
right
[Music]
damn that guy's getting better days i'm
gonna let you try and figure it out for
a while and then all that well i think i
need both hands right this is a kind of
a both hand situation yes sir
so let's grab it
yeah i got this i think
let's roll it up come on nice and easy
nice why does it do that
what i don't understand okay here let's
just use this hand apparently
[Music]
oh can i give him a hint i got shells
not yet he's working on it okay
[Music]
soon
okay so that's not working how about a
bucket
let's throw [ __ ] at him [ __ ] you oh
okay uh there's gotta be something here
oh what's this
oh okay
can i grab onto this or something
[Music]
oh i got an idea you gotta you gotta
zelda it a little bit
if you know what i'm saying oh i got a
zelda in
great call dan gnarlier the better
oh thank you here let's get this in
there
nice i was gonna say god of war it that
works too
well it doesn't seem to be wanting to go
in yeah you got the right idea though
you just got to find the right place to
jam
okay let's walk over here
look carefully at the wheel itself that
you're spinning
[Music]
like the the bike tire is there oh here
we go
hello
all right now let's move on over here
okay oh
see i don't know why i keep having false
jumps
i think you're flicking the uh right
stick
[Music]
oh you better work quick though oh don't
celebrate too long
[Music]
grab weapon with primary hand
got it hurry up it's getting louder oh
[ __ ]
i dropped my shells i dropped my shelves
this fan is falling off
the headset is falling off oh it's not
tight enough i think because when i look
down it falls off
oh your your helmet your your yeah my
helmet
here help him out how the [ __ ] do i load
this thing
uh you so press the reload button it's
gonna pop open the chamber
oh i see it yeah and then toss that
puppy
in there and close it wait
[Music]
it needs to be tighter i've got like a
tiny [ __ ] baby head apparently
[Music]
uh-huh and now you gotta [ __ ] it hey you
got it
this thing tighter okay that's the knob
on the back
oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
you're out of ammo av is [ __ ] with
this thing and it's freaking out
[Music]
yeah oh yeah it's good i can't find the
buttons
where's the button
[Music]
[Music]
why can't i pick up my gun i can only
have one gun no you got it you got it
you're just panicking yeah okay
i don't want to get shot
i'm being told by chad that the cushion
on your head is for children
oh well he did say he has a little baby
well yeah i mean that's not
he's saying it's still too big
there you go all right i think i'm all
like tangled up and [ __ ] all right i
think the danger's passed let's uh let's
help you adjust now
oh my god you guys when it gets tighter
it gets all blurry i have to
readjust oh my god you guys
i'm all tangled up
take that off what's happening
okay thank you thank you
okay thank you thank you
thank you dan thank you dan wow that was
intense okay
so
[Music]
okay so your right hand
has in the center uh like a little
touchpad thing
that's how you bring up your inventory
of your different guns yeah i did i was
doing that but
right and so now and now slide in the
direction of the item that you want to
pick
i think it was just that you were
panicking and so you yeah
you got it now there you go i was
panicking yeah all right we got options
now people
[Music]
so these are little schmutzy uh little
[ __ ] so that's the little head crabs
know die
thank you wendy
[Music]
did you just
no so the part the problem is that
the problem is that it accidentally
jumps all the time because my hands are
so small
that i'm actually triggering the jump
which is down
all right moving forward right and um
i just jumped into the pit so that
happened oops so i got it oh good it
saved it oh that's
okay you're good yeah i was worried
about that too all right
who's in here hello
can you imagine gordon for alex do you
walk around like this
what would you walk around like if you
if i was really doing recon like this i
guess
uh yeah no i prefer no you look really
cool keep doing that
no no it's jumping when i'm
i don't want to jump do you have your
finger over the thumb stick
oh you guys because you you should just
remove your thumb from
the thumb stick you don't unless you're
trying to jump okay boomer
no it turns left and right as well oh
right right wrong one okay boomer
there's got to be some oh hello
daddy there's probably an option
to change that if you want to [ __ ] with
the menus
some kind of good thing in here right
yeah that looks like a uh supply chest
or something literally no
empty no no thanks gabe newell
an to put an empty chest
okay um
oh what's up [ __ ] come
come get it come get it yeah that's what
i thought
next death to all of them
i got it yes okay two mags left oh
chat says the first time he loots the
crate and it's empty i know exactly
oh that's got to be goods right
nope empty well
babe had something up there you probably
should have
pulled it down with your gloves there
was stuff up there i mean i don't know
but
now we'll never know right
what's up [ __ ] you think you want some
of this we'll come get some then
come get some right now dude who wants
someone else
[Music]
my head grabs coming at you
i don't want to waste ammo you're still
alive
there's one there's still alive
i'm gonna back up into the pit you
[ __ ]
yeah can i head can i piss the whip i
don't know
if there's melee damage in this game i
genuinely don't know
the [ __ ] thing [ __ ]
they're like i have never seen someone
last one
okay i enough of this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[Music]
yeah if you've ever wanted to kill
somebody clap everybody clap
all right so i need to get into new
fresh i'm out
[Applause]
so why can't i switch this shot d okay
right so you gotta so once you have the
shells you gotta hit the
what normally would be the magazine
button there you go and then load them
in
close it ammo so it you can only load
i believe two oh no you can't don't
listen to me i thought you could only
get a couple shots in there so how many
got it
you have five right now all right well
looks like uh
i'm gonna just be running through this
and praying
you do have more pistol ammo though i
don't know if that's what you were
saying something over there
maybe an upgrade maybe
you still have that resin i got some red
i have like more than 10 now
oh hello oh yes there we go
we got canned soup we got canned soup
and a pack of ciggies let's go
i could use a smoke right now
oh you think you're smart smoking big
joints [ __ ] off
what i really need is ammunition and it
looks like i found some
is there anything else in here you
should so you should
switch to your pistol and reload now so
that you don't
flip the [ __ ] out next time that you're
getting attacked i have three bullets
left
no i'm saying in your pistol
[Music]
oh you're saying i can i can already
yeah you have one bullet in there
i can load her up already yes okay
i seem to be pushing the eject button i
need a machine gun
remember switching to your pistol is
always faster than reloading
okay i remember you what do i do with
you
probably need to get my [ __ ] little
schmutz ray out okay
what's ray yeah you have a puzzle here
puzzle time chet is saying dan let him
suffer
dan let me stop okay i'm about the
people i'm just um
the man suffer dan should she suffer
clap if i should suffer
somebody said that and trying to clap if
you want him to suffer
oh yeah a lot of clubs
here i'll be honest here i'm going to
turn on the chat for you for a second
here we go look at the chest
look at the chat real quick okay chat
everybody's clapping for me to suffer
laugh if i should suffer oh thank you
guys thank you
clap if you want somebody to die if
you've ever wanted somebody to die
let's go you guys we finally get
the upgrade we've all dreamed of
okay how many resin we got 12
looks like the only thing you can buy is
the site display that highlights
tactical targets
that seems boring but okay
what do i got to install it now i mean
what the [ __ ] insert your resin
it's like poker chips
what i got to do everything in this game
[Music]
and it's a sexual dance
[Music]
a lot of people saying waste of resin
that really went really
i haven't played so i don't know it
looks sick though no i mean
you got a cool ass little hologram now
sorry
oh oh you waste ammo every time you do
that oh i got like a little sight are
you kidding me that's sick
[Music]
all right let's not waste any more ammo
now
so oh that jumping thing is super
annoying
i hear ab loading don't worry about it
screaming some supplies i need supplies
man my
i am low on ammunition oh hello
little little [ __ ] little unit
he sounds so sweet
[Music]
can i squish his little body over here i
there was a health thing uh back on the
wall back by the resin machine
yeah you're such a sweet little cute guy
i love you so much
we do a little trolling it's called we
do a little trolling bye
nobody liked you i was just kidding
let the bugs die i'm kidding i feel bad
i'm vegan now for two days so that feels
bad
thank you zach uh step back into frame
you're like
you're right i support you ethan there
you go get in there
get in there
did anyone see that but me
no nobody saw that by me also
dude supplies is everything
[Music]
okay feeling good geared up good health
oh my god it's so dark are you kidding
me right now
okay so do i go in the
do i go in the gutter
don't be loading up on me maybe i don't
go this way
go back out the other way
[Music]
should i bring the soup
[Music]
absolutely that was where you came from
maybe
no i don't think so no well then i see
some good [ __ ] here
hello
wait i don't want to leave the soup here
[Music]
okay let's bring the soup oh my god this
is challenging hello
what's this oh more ammo thank god
all right guys as long as i have the
soup i'm safe
this is my lucky soup can
as long as i have soup i'm safe nothing
can harm me
as long as i have cookies for you what
so no uh cookies for you i don't need
cookies i have soup
too dark you'll need a flashlight okay
good idea i think you're right
are you hungry [ __ ] are you hungry
use your site yeah who's hungry soup
time oh it actually oh what the [ __ ]
wait i'm just missing all my shots so
like
[Music]
oh great
what in my ear it [ __ ] ricocheted
into my ear
okay why okay here okay dude chill down
chill dude i wish i had a crowbar i want
to go melee on him
i really do oh oh oh
oh god this reload is like
okay come here come here you [ __ ]
come here come here come here
here enjoy this play with this
[Music]
okay am i wasting more ammo trying to
blow this thing up
are you kidding me right now
i don't like this side it's making me
worse my
my my shooting gets worse now we know
why people said it was a waste of resin
it like
how am i out of ammo already i just got
a bunch man
all right well you switched to the
shotgun are you out on the pillar i'm
out it says i'm out
said one bullet left well the good news
is i have soup
as long as i have soup i can't be harmed
oh hello
here here let's put this
stop jumping okay let's put the soup
down
thank you thank you
okay fantastic
soup soup is coming with me okay i've
got soup
nobody come at me i've got this can of
soup
i can feel av near me
[Music]
that's new buddy
oh my god i'm really going to waste my
aim on this hey come here come here i
know exactly what to do
what
what maybe squirting me
oh [ __ ]
the thing is it it i just changed
oh my god you guys
yeah no [ __ ]
i just changed controller so i'm a
little bit panicking
oh my god dude bye [ __ ] you
yeah i know [ __ ] stressing me out
bye can i just leave him bye leave me
the [ __ ] alone
where's my soup bye oh no did we lose
the soup
oh bro i think i think i actually you
got to reload
you're safe no i didn't lose the soup i
know exactly where it is
[Music]
you think i lost the soup dan what kind
of heartless maniac do you think i am
here hey oh what
i can use this oh wait what i wonder if
i can use this
[Music]
no i got this suit sick dude
let's just go in there for safekeeping
pretty sure i need this oh
um problem
problem i need to get through this
which i can't do you
turn on a shot for this
wait hold on i mean i just oh i see i
see
okay right so
oh that was it
[Music]
there's probably more eh yeah
so where's this go oh now that's on i
see it's a little tricky
tricky tricky gabe uh oh uh oh what the
[ __ ] is this [ __ ] no [ __ ]
way i'm deep undercover oh no okay so i
gotta
hmm soup you're coming with
come on
[Music]
okay i'll see you later i'm coming back
for you soup
don't worry never leave a fallen
soldier behind ever
oh we don't want that powered
something with these shells eh
[Music]
oh they go through interesting the
shells go through
the ethan does not go through figure
that one out
the shells go through the ethan does not
go through
curious
the shells go through oh there's another
one up here
so so maybe if we twisty that now daddy
can get through
did i even get okay so let's go this way
okay i'm gonna need a gun for this part
okay hello
does it lock no
hmm i think that means it's locked
baby what are you working on here i'm
just getting a
size for a suit real quick
excuse me i'm playing a intense video
game hold on uh
maybe he's getting sized for tux if you
could just yeah let's stand by for a
second
can we just pause the game just stand by
just stand by for a second we're uh okay
av is getting sized for a tux right now
so can we see
av yeah i mean are we just supposed to
watch you all day i got stuff to do
okay how's his dimensions looking good i
like the twilight movies
he says he's skinny he's a skinny ledge
skinny legend yeah
okay is it okay if i continue maybe yeah
yeah sure thank you
the a b gets tried for a tux podcast
well i'm not really sure what to make of
all this
at the moment because it's like
this side if this side opens
would you like the chats help sure
uh stand by look i'm not i haven't fully
uh
all right chat i haven't fully now don't
don't give him bad information oh that
wouldn't be good
don't don't give him bad information
okay so your chat's enabled if you want
to take a peek at what they have to say
i s well i'm confused because this thing
was just open
right turn the attorney turn eternity
so there's only two paths apparently
and neither of them are doing what i
need them to do
the the chat's on if you want a little
tip it is open
okay yeah no i got it's okay you got it
figured out
i'm gonna figure it out okay and then
and then we got this blue
he doesn't need to chat i thought you
guys wanted me to suffer well which is
it
you know what i'm saying i mean
listening to the chat give advice is
a form of suffering
so obviously can i turn it from here
no oh i
know what to do you guys
you guys
i just had a jstation moment you guys
you guys
people say i'm a hater for saying that i
mean come on get real did i just solve
the puzzle oh
with no help we got one open we got two
open oh
i still don't know what to do though
[Laughter]
is there more
guys guys well this is kind of intense
okay
so this one is running this is the one i
just connected
and then um
that one closes that one
so i guess i just wanna i mean they're
both down
there something i need to do here
i do need my soup back
i haven't forgot about the soup have we
checked what kind of soup it is
do we know it's hard to tell us wasn't
in english
um was it in like russian or something
yeah it looked russian
anybody who speaks russian let us know
what type of soup that is
all right chad what do you got for me
psych it doesn't work
i mean here's something here probably
need to get that charged up eh
oh i did it oh people have a good point
what if it's not soup and it's like
beans or something
bro oh [ __ ] well what the [ __ ] am i
okay now what it goes back that way
goes that way
guys vladimir
putin what if i close it on myself in
here is that helpful at all
can i even
checking for uh checking the uh
electrical capabilities here
checking checking the electrics well if
this goes on does anything interesting
happen over here no
maybe that door goes up
[Music]
huh
[Music]
do i have chat
can i do like a oh a longi
[Music]
oh my god you guys
[Music]
so frustrating
like that that seems to like be a puzzle
piece doesn't it
chad is saying lift the goddamn garage
door
okay so i have to get on that oh for
real then i i was in there the whole
[ __ ] time
oh well what the [ __ ] i figured this
[ __ ] out years ago
and my soup has been here waiting for me
i probably need both hands eh cam you
can cut out all this [ __ ]
yes oh hello
can i help you
[Music]
oh [ __ ] there's a flashlight down there
you see that
[Music]
what do you see that
where's the suit the chat is spamming
don't edit anything out cam
cam don't you dare all right fine
[Music]
who cares let's go
[Music]
who gives a [ __ ] let's go
all right i'm on a quest for soup
yo you see that flashlight folks
it is dark everything look what they
found
did can anyone read this it says
yeah it could be beans it's possible
you know it's possible for sure
stop ejecting ammo out of the chamber
the chair says
oh do i keep doing that because i feel
like i should have way more ammo
um hello something
[Music]
here
[Music]
[Music]
um gravity glove gravity glove gravity
glove
[Music]
oh man here take it
[Music]
oh [ __ ] oh thank god okay wow awesome
do i really keep ejecting ammo that's so
annoying it's
the chat saying you are spewing ammo it
hurts to watch i don't know why
oh no my soup
god bless this bloom boomer got it
i'm playing on hearts what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] you take my suit [ __ ]
okay
well that's like a big ass crab huh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] i got slimed ah
can you die please
uh do i have oh
uh yeah can you just uh
about what about anything uh
oh god bye big fan of this flashlight
it's not unlike yourself it's also
sensitive to the dark oh yeah
meaning it should go on automatically
when the lights go out did they leave
space okay i have no ammo and it's
driving me crazy
oh i don't even know
um ow you hit me in the head
i have no [ __ ] bullets what do i do
if i have no bullets
i have zero bullets i can't do that and
run away
what do i do i have no bullets dan take
accountability dude
i have no bullets
oh that guy with the ground okay you
shouldn't
see any ammo around here because i have
no [ __ ] bullets
and i'm right on a wall i miss you i
miss my old friend uh
i would that's the thing you need a
crowbar
okay what's this oh
like that i do like that
okay just some advice from the chat
they say stop dropping bullets and you
will have bullets i'm trying
i don't know why i keep dropping bullets
okay
okay literally slide okay can you die
please
i just dropped bullets
[Music]
oh my god you guys
ow all right who wants some of this [ __ ]
don't miss so you can see the white of
their eyes
[Music]
and the great and the words of the great
george washington
how's my health who said it then
somebody said it
hamilton was it alexander hamilton
dude you're causing me a lot of grief
bro
[ __ ] okay tell me when i drop ammo
because i really don't know when i'm
doing it and i
you know it's causing me a lot of
problems
[Music]
just looking for ammo i think i'm just
saying don't reload
until you're completely empty that's
that's the secret
oh what a secret thank you guys
amazing
okay i think we did good actually we
salvaged this situation a little bit
right yeah sure
i think i needed to hold it like this
any baddies here
just you know what i'm saying oh
you think i forgot about you
jump jump
did i get him nope of course not why
would i get him
why would i with a [ __ ] shotgun
get him
don't slimey huh
i'm getting good on
where is he am i covered in goo
okay where the [ __ ]
hey baddie
you trying to run from me you were
trying to
run from me that's not how this works
hey i just went and got measured for my
tux um
do you still have the soup he lost the
soup unfortunately the [ __ ]
no no no no no i'll get the soup i need
to recover
no i will get the soup dan better ye of
little fish you better
the soup is forever
all right guys it looks like we have
prevailed
seriously
okay like how does that help me
oh i got the flashlight that's how it
helps me
okay all right let me the [ __ ] out of
here
hate this life
okay oh
yo this scope is dog [ __ ]
oh my god you guys
last one yeah i know thank you
what is the point of this scope it's
like impossible to hit them
damn
all right
no baddies hey
let's use the dot check this family
he's running you little [ __ ] ass
uh-oh talk [ __ ]
too quickly
last four shots
okay
god you guys
thank you peace and love peace and love
here let's bring i wonder if this
i can use as a weapon like pretty spiky
pretty deadly looking
right zero ammo
zero and ammo andy
oh my god more here see what happens
see what happens when you get this
dropped on you nothing
bye
did i have no rest i really need you to
talk again
absolutely be specific um before
what was life like before the combine ah
excellent
alex have you ever heard of one shell
that will be useful
nope not one right to make a club
sandwich you need to start with bread
not from a bread line from a bakery
across the street
baked that day okay you add tomatoes
lettuce
not vegetable paste you have real pizza
that's from an animal you toast the
bread wait
okay okay okay i can't do this
that's insane i have a shell and i'm not
done wait did i knock you jerk
oh my god you guys first one you put ham
in it
also from a peck and turkey from an
animal we used to call
the turkey
it was the most impossible food item you
could imagine
oh any age before wow
i know right that is
wow thanks you're welcome alex did i see
some explosive
this looks pretty uh explosive no
oh here thank you oh there's stuff back
there
i cannot see a [ __ ] thing
okay who wants some of this who wants um
enjoy your snack little [ __ ] rooney
[Music]
did they kill them both let's go right
now
[Music]
clap please clap please clap
still more baddies though until now
god aim ammo yes please
whatever this is yes please a can of
speaking of cans um the soup is gone dan
the soup is gone
ethan yeah you have to go back
i don't remember where i left it i'll be
totally honest with you dan
okay you know what we're just gonna have
to take one for the team on this one
how's my health probably not great so
can we smash the little bug oh there's a
bug back here
yay look at ethan he knows how to play
[Music]
how proud are we of ethan take a couple
steps back so the grid isn't
in your face hey look at that even
better
ethan klein is is damaging everything
making it all worse okay let's go let's
look at this cute bug you're so sweet
you are so sweet we love you
um into the incinerator
[Music]
bye get squished chad is very upset
about the soup and they're not over
it well i can go back but i just i
really genuinely don't remember where i
left it i was
it's been very stressful you guys please
forgive me we'll find a new soup
we will find an oh are you [ __ ]
kidding me right now
this is this is the
can oh i can't look at it
i don't know if i'm holding it or not
dude this is the can of soup
there's no such thing as a coincidence
there's no such thing as a coincidence
okay we got the soup boys we're back in
business
all right people listen up
we got a can of soup and i'm not afraid
to use it
i mean it's russian what do you want
from me somebody please
that understands russian it says
here let's put it safely here okay oh no
here we'll leave it right there okay
vladimir putin
seriously
okay some people saying it says
vegetable soup in russian
i was right i'm gonna hold on hold on
vegetable
soup translate oh yeah be able to say
that [ __ ] for sure
all right hold it up to the screen again
okay wait wait i'm not dealing with this
hold on this is more important no it's
no no no no
[Music]
what
[Music]
i bet you're still alive dude
i no he's dead as [ __ ] good job bye bye
oh
oh my god good reloading is so [ __ ]
stressful in this game
i am going to lose my mind
oh my god you guys now you're living
dude what do you want to shoot him 20
times
[Music]
wake up
now you're living
thank you wally i know wally would have
my back if you were here now
that looked like um that looked like
ammo in there
what you thought milk carton on me
okay
[ __ ] [ __ ]
dude he's got a milk carton i don't want
any of that trouble semen
is another kind of milk
where's the dot
[Music]
[Music]
one left okay alex so dramatic
there's got another be another explodey
here's an exploding
[ __ ]
[Music]
come here
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god you guys oh god
oh my god you guys this is so stressful
i think i'm losing
i think i'm losing years of my life to
this game
one clip is that the best you could do
for me uplife
one shell
[Music]
dude if i had a crowbar i could do this
whole playthrough with the crowbar
i guess that's gordon ramsay's thing not
alex's
how we doing here looking good feeling
good
three hearts you know what it is
oh somebody in the chat suggested heart
rate monitor for you
while doing this that could be fun i'll
be like they'll be like ethan it says
your resting heart rate is 175 that
can't be right
off the charts but always in your hearts
wow sometimes you really blow my mind
zach dude zach
thank you man you have been seriously
i mean you're always good but lately i
don't know thank you i appreciate that
look
he takes his craft seriously and that's
that's all i could ask from him
i appreciate it was so bad it was
instant thank you i mean yeah that's why
he's the best
in the game thank you better in the game
that means a lot
um excuse me but okay [ __ ]
oh you [ __ ] dirty boy there's
something behind me
i'm getting for your [ __ ] good
all right we got bullets at least okay
[ __ ] you were going to do this the hard
way
i guess the scope is kind of dope
actually
oh no not the not the big annoying one
[ __ ] [ __ ] all right i'm just running
what huh come here get me [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
off
my mouth what'd you just squirt my mouth
okay i can deal with that this is water
are you it doesn't sound like it is by
the way you're laughing spit in my mouth
look in my eyes wait does he have like
an explosive in his pocket
okay i'm getting good on bro daddy
doesn't like getting good on
there's explosives everywhere and i'm
just can't get my [ __ ] together
okay oh my god you kidding me
you [ __ ] kidding right now
i could have got him all with that one
man
seriously
okay
[ __ ] welcome back for you
i saw another explosive thing
here come here come here come here
come here come here come here you [ __ ]
come here
[Music]
okay ethan's getting better at this game
right oh no i hate this thing
okay you know what
daddy's not playing this time
daddy's not playing down to two
yeah don't worry about it i can't even
see [ __ ]
okay yeah it doesn't work
dude the cocky i mean what the [ __ ]
oh my god okay
die die
oh
i'm all soaked covered in [ __ ]
sweating freaking out this is a pretty
good workout minutes left
three mags let's go sounds good to me
so i'm pretty sure wasn't there mac here
there was a mag here oh
he took it what kind of [ __ ] maniac
is that what are you gonna do with those
[Music]
what's with the dogs they're in the way
he's worried about me
oh that's creepy last thing i need a
scooby-doo involved in this [ __ ]
all right oh my god dude i'm sweating
i am stressed i am afraid i am small
thank you more dark
somebody been sleeping here damn that's
a bad
that's a bad situation oh at loading
should we call that is that a good
checkpoint or should i go further
what do you think ab you watch the other
playthroughs
let's call that let's call it we can
savor the game
and i want to get the bot up
yeah yeah it's a good place a lot of
people saying deepa
deeper here just just for
just for fun uh here i just i
subject to the whole you guys i just
turned the chat back on take a look at
the feedback okay let's see well of
course they're saying deeper
deeper deeper deeper
i'm saying lots of deeper
[Music]
oh my god the problem is i wanted to get
the bot up on the channel today
where did um where do people usually end
their let their part too i mean that
seemed like a decent checkpoint i
suppose yeah let's just end it here
okay let's just take a nap right in this
beautiful uh peaceful
you know what could be better yeah no
it's it's a nice setup in here carton of
milk
is there any soup um look for the soup
i have the russian translation this one
is pulled out a different can
oh yeah let's go in the light so you can
get a good look at it oh yeah i'll turn
off the chat so you can what do we got
here guys
that looks nice oh maybe it's some kind
of coffee maybe oh yeah coffee
natural coffee excellent so you can find
that soup there's gotta be some soup in
there there's actually soup everywhere
i've noticed oh what is this
oh she's a radio [ __ ] you
wait is my flashlight off why
who are you to decide if i need a
flashlight
the flashlight automatically turns on
oh i'm gonna have to fight combine
soldiers
you know what that means
no i don't like it
oh oh i hear the engine wrapping
no i don't like a hat sound
die i don't like that sound
i won't shoot you until the combine
starts shooting on you alright a little
teaser for part three
i'm sweating my balls off okay whoa
okay that was fun we made progress guys
can you see how sweaty i am
i can't really tell on camera but i
believe you oh yeah you're done
there's [ __ ] all over the place all
right guys thanks for watching
we will be back um on thursday that's
right
all right thanks guys see you then tata
bye bye
[Music]